die brehmstraße im ostwestfälischen
bielefeld scheint die wohl letzte
autofreie zone der republik zu sein
seit juni gilt hier ein absolutes park
und halteverbot auf beiden seiten
laut stadt ist die straße für müllabfuhr
feuerwehren straßenreinigung zu eng wenn
ihr auch noch autos stünden der straße
fielen sage und schreibe zwei zentimeter
die betroffenen anwohner sind stinksauer
das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein können
nicht einfach schilder aufstellen und
parkverbot hier hinsetzen absolutes
halteverbot unmöglich wie gesagt ich
habe morgens und abends ein pflegedienst
und die wissen nicht wo sie den wagen
hinstellen sollen 50 jahren wurde hier
konnte man parken ohne dass sich einer
beschwert hat und plötzlich auf heute
auf morgen ohne irgendjemanden zu
informieren oder irgendwas zu sagen
machen sie ein beispiel ein
jahrzehntelang war alles kein problem
auf der einen seite wurde geparkt auf
der anderen seite lief der verkehr
doch dann fängt die stadt an die straße
zu vermessen ergebnis für parkende autos
und die feuerwehr soll die straße
plötzlich zu eng seien deshalb verhängt
die stadt im sommer das absolute
halteverbot das problem als die
brehmstraße vor jahren saniert wurde
soll die fahrbahn fünf meter 3 breit
werden so der plan der stadt tatsächlich
sind es gerade mal vier meter 80
geworden
zwar sind jetzt die gehwege breiter aber
da darf man sich auch nicht drauf
stellen die straße ist zu eng gebaut und
die anwohner müssen das ausbaden
man fühlt sich ein bisschen verarscht
wenn man nicht weiterging im bielefelder
rathaus will uns niemand ein interview
geben aber die absurde parksituation in
der bremer straße ist mittlerweile
chefsache schriftlich heißt es der
oberbürgermeister hat die fachverwaltung
um eine rechtliche einschätzung gebieten
anfangen der kommenden woche wird der
verwaltungschef dann über das weitere
vorgehen entscheiden
für die menschen in der brehmstraße
steht fest so wie es jetzt ist kann es
nicht bleiben wenn wir besuch bekommen
alte tante kann nicht laufen
nicht mal halten was soll das wer eine
sachgerechte planung ist das nicht
selbst werden diese straße jetzt frei
ist also die die zufahrtstraßen zur
brehmstraße die sind umso voller geparkt
alle die sonst hier stehen quetschen
sich nun notgedrungen in die
nebenstraßen und müssen wasser kisten
und koffer bis zu ihrer haustür schier
endlos spazieren tragen